yeah man one of the things that i'm kind
of excited about is
i talk a lot to the typical media that
knows
the very simplified version
of what's been going on with ufo mystery
but i also talk a lot with people who
are just
way into ufos i appreciate that you're
neither of those and we might have a
different conversation
so yeah anything you want to talk about
that is interest to you and your
audience is fine with me
recently i had the pleasure of speaking
with jeremy corbell a documentary
filmmaker who specializes in what he
calls the extraordinary
so ufos aliens and the like it might
seem like a departure from the academic
chaperone
that you're used to from this channel
but keep in mind that the goal has
always been to give you
in-depth analyses on topics that are
abstract
in such a way that you can't find it
pretty much anywhere else because i
believe
you're far smarter than other podcasts
give you credit for
and that if you don't understand some
terminology or some mathematical concept
it's just a google search way you can
learn it if you want to put the time in
alternatively you can go to the
subreddit a new one which is recently
launched for this channel
called r theories of everything
dedicated to expositing on
theories of everything this level of
somewhat reckoned
detail is necessary if we want to get to
the bottom of
the fundamental laws of physics rather
than stay at the surface okay so how
does this all relate to jeremy corbell
recall that i'm of the opinion that a
large breakthrough is necessary
in physics and i have a feeling it's
going to come from the outside though i
can't prejudice myself as to where the
signal or series of signals will come
from the ordinary physics community
draws the line at consciousness you know
this
the ordinary member of the public draws
the line at the supernatural or the
paranormal
now i don't draw those lines i find it
dubious in pretty much each direction
whether consciousness is fundamental or
ontologically primitive or
whether aliens exist or not i'm
unconvinced in each direction however
i'm still willing to explore it if
aliens do
exist then that means there's new
physics
see i'm i don't see technological
applications like some of the engineers
i happen to be theoretically trained so
i see
or at least i perceive potential new
physics
and that excites me now i have some
issues with the way that gravity wave
amplification is used
because i don't see that as a coherent
concept i don't understand it unless i
see the equations
it's ill-defined to me i also don't like
the use of
the word dimension to speak about
alternate realities because to me the
word
dimension is reserved for a degree of
freedom
i also have a pet peeve of people saying
space and time
there is no space and time there is only
space time
not even hyphen is technically
space-time it's a four-dimensional
manifold
it's one object there's no such thing as
separate space
there's no such thing as separate time
either way if during the interview you
see me somewhat
subdued or quiet during those parts it's
because inside my head
i'm making a woo yang dictionary-like
substitution
and i didn't see the need to correct it
in real time because it doesn't change
much of the underlying meaning and
there's no sense slowing down the
conversation for what will be perceived
as pedantry
jeremy corbell is undaunted and has my
respect
and commendations i'm lucky because this
might be one of the most sobering and
enlightening videos with him
please support at patreon.com
kurtjmungle
if you'd like to see more videos like
this because
right now i'm doing it pretty much pro
bono
and it takes quite a bit of time to do
the preparation since the goal is to
investigate with each guest
at a more benthic level deeper
and more academic let's say than any
other interview with them
enjoy i'm here with jeremy corbell
thank you jeremy i appreciate you coming
on thanks for having me on kurt
you know you and me are similar in that
we're filmmakers we're
both one-man fans in that i
write direct edit produce
shoot my own films how about yourself
yeah that's the only way i know how i'd
love to work with other people i just
haven't uh
gotten there yet so i do everything on
my own right what's the thought process
that you go through to
select the topics for your films
yeah well i you know
the premise for each film that i've put
out i've done a lot of investigations i
haven't made films
on each investigation the the premise
has always been
can i move the ball forward can i bring
something to light
show it in a way that hasn't been done
before
that will alter the narrative that will
bring new information
and so that's kind of been my passion in
one senses
that i i would like to uplift the
the visual aesthetic on this topic that
i love which is ufos and the mysterious
and the unknown
but that i can also move the ball
forward so that's kind of been my
two-prong approach i mean i'm not a
i i didn't know if i was a filmmaker i'd
never made films before i got i lucked
out i put one out on netflix called
patient 17. it was my first film
ever that i submitted and got picked up
but with all of my films what you'll see
is that i'm trying to humanize
the individuals who i'm speaking with
it's there's no script
uh in in the standard sense they're
long-form investigative documentaries
where i embed myself in people's lives
and their belief systems their
extraordinary beliefs
i'm not choosing sides and saying
someone should believe this or someone
should believe that
i always leave it open to the viewer and
i show it just as it is
this is what happened this is what's
going on
you know you need to decide for yourself
reality and so i'm not preaching to
anybody
in my films the world is mysterious i
have more questions than answers
so yeah have you always been interested
in the paranormal
yeah i don't you know i'm kind of
allergic to that word because i i don't
know what normal
is you know i i let's just use
what i mean is what the general public
would call paranormal
yeah it's just that uh i'd like to kind
of combat that idea that
things are considered paranormal like
like germs
were considered at one time magical and
it's just because we didn't understand
them
and so i think that we have a lot of
catching up to do
these mysteries exist they these things
occur and putting your head in the sand
is not going to do anything
so getting to understand the way that
people engage what i call the phenomenon
which includes the paranormal
but is also related to ufos uh
it's important that we understand that
we might not
understand it all yet and so that's the
kind of premise of my series
extraordinary beliefs and all the films
is
you know let's let's talk about these
things
for people who are watching who are my
audience my usual audience it might seem
like a departure this interview because
i usually
talk to professors of physics and so on
yeah and
the channel is called theories of
everything so the goal is
to explicate the current theories of
everything as well as to generate my own
and it's somewhat of a process because
i'm taking input from the audience
there's some people with
let's say outrageous theories
that or theories that are considered to
be non-rigorous
and i welcome them unlike most people
and the reason is that
i think that the innovation is going to
come from the fringe rather than the
center and i could be wrong about that
but
that's my intuition so why am i
interviewing jeremy why am i
interviewing you one of the reasons is
that
what's held physics back for the past
40 years is a paucity of data so
a lack of data and one of the reasons
for that is it's
high energy physics is it's extremely
expensive
when i look at someone like bob lazar
and bob lazar i would think of him more
as a
an extremely sophisticated engineer
rather than a theoretical physicist
and i think that he considers himself to
be an engineer but i could be wrong
either way he looks at it as technology
and many and many of the interviews with
ufos they talk about technology
technology
now i see it from a theoretical physics
standpoint
i don't see technology i see new
fundamental physics
and i'm curious i'm so curious if any of
this is true
well there's breakthroughs for
a potential theory of everything for
example there's something called so10
which is unflipped so10 which is a
unification of the weak and
electromagnetic and strong force but it
doesn't incorporate gravity it's pretty
good theory
but i heard lazar refer to the strong
force as gravity number two something
like that
now that like i would i would love to
explore but either way
i think that you have some it might not
be mathematical but you have some
ideas as to what possible new
technologies new physics exists and i
just want to speculate like
mad here yeah the physics of it's
amazing but let's back way the [ __ ] up
you know for your audience um people
might not know so let's uh
start with this so my name is jeremy
corbell i'm a documentary filmmaker i
make uh
you know investigative documentaries i
recently released one
that was in netflix smash hit went all
around the world hundreds of millions of
views
uh i went on the joe rogan podcast three
times with three different individuals
that i brought
with with me that all relate to this
topic
of ufos uh the man you mentioned bob
lazar in case people don't know
bob lazar is the man he's the reason why
the in the public consciousness you know
about area 51
and flying saucers bob lazar is the
reason for that
he came forward in 1989 over 30 years
ago
and talked about how our government the
united states government
was attempting to reverse engineer these
extraterrestrial machines
machines from other worlds and that he
participated
in that attempt to reverse engineer
those spacecraft
people called him a fraud a liar they
tried to dig into his personal life and
you know decide that he's not telling us
the truth about ufos because
he ran a brothel or you know all this
crazy [ __ ] but
bottom line is after 30 plus years bob
lazar's story
stands true he he did exactly what he
said he did
now people don't need to believe that
there's a much bigger picture going on
here
the big picture is this do does our
government the united states government
or world governments do they have craft
from other civilizations advanced
civilizations that are technologically
more advanced and operate in the realm
of physics that is beyond
our understanding that's the question
bob azar has always said
i can't prove everything in my story but
over time you'll see it's true
and the big thing for bob
was that bob is a scientist so the big
thing for bob
was the science and technology that's
being hold back
from humanity that are represented in
these craft
now we couldn't replicate them we
couldn't reproduce them significantly
in any way because the material science
was the number one thing that held us
back but
we did get an understanding how they
operate how they use gravity wave
amplification
to traverse space time all of this
sounds like science fiction if i was
talking to you
five years ago but in december of 2018
there was the announcement that the
united states government
had a program called atip advanced
aerospace
threat identification program this
program
was tasked with identifying and tracking
and trying to observe the flight
characteristics and patterns
of what we call ufos non-terrestrial
vehicles
so it has been admitted that the united
states military
is investigating the ufo problem and
that they've been doing so
actively there was another program
called awsap
advanced aerospace weapon systems
application program
this was the mother program that housed
the the a-tip program
new york times came out and said these
programs are real
and not only that but we have fighter
pilots like commander david fravor who
came forward who chased the ufo for the
united states government
i was the person that was able to get
him first
on record long form audio coming forward
also
first filmed interview coming forward i
also got the guy
uh chad underwood he is now commander
commander chad underwood he's the guy
that
filmed the tic tac ufo the now famous
tic tac ufo
so that's kind of the brief history of
what's been going on
with babazar and ufos but we're now at a
place
we understand how they work it is not
our against our
physics how they work we have to
reimagine
what we don't understand about physics
it's gravity wave amplification
okay at times i'm going to slow you down
or ask you to repeat because
i don't know too much about this is i
have a brief foray into
the ufo phenomena so when you say atip
and osap and so on i might get you to
repeat them
one for our audience but two for me to
write down to ask you some more
questions and to investigate later
i just learned about john lear today so
i was just watching some of your
i think it was episode one about john
johnson yeah i abandoned that project a
while ago i filmed
with john for about eight years seven or
eight years and you know he's the
godfather of conspiracy he's he's not
the touchstone of truth that i go to
about the ufo thing
he's wild but as an individual i really
liked him you know so i filmed
with him for yeah about seven or eight
years right john deere mentioned that he
saw
some object on the moon do you recall
what he's referring to
john lear's told me a lot of things you
know people living on the sun that kind
of thing
i would not take anything that john leer
says
as you know a touchstone of truth for
the ufo topic he is as fringe as fringe
gets
i didn't document him because i believed
him
i documented him because he's a
character you know he's the son of
william piller inventor of the the
learjet
and the eight track stereo and motorola
company and
he's an interesting guy babazar stands
aside
babazar was an employee hired through
egmg
to work at a sub-base of area 51 called
site 4 where he was tasked specifically
with the power and propulsion of these
non-terrestrial craft and trying to back
engineer them who else do you find
credible there's bob lazar
john lee or no david fravor
and then you mentioned the guy who
actually took the video of the tic tac
yeah there's a lot of people in
in the ufo field right but there's
individuals who are kind of keystones
along the way
why commander fravor is so credible
because he's a trained observer
he's a fighter pilot with more hours
than anybody that was out
on that mission right and not only did
he engage
this tic-tac-shaped ufo that defied
our known physics its propulsion system
was a reactionless system
usually things push something out the
back and they go forward this had none
of that
it was a gravitational system you could
tell by the acceleration the lack of the
sonic boom the instantaneous control
turns and speeds so commander fraber is
a trained observer who came forward
both in in briefings to congress private
briefings to congress
as well in intelligence reports and then
publicly once i was able to really bring
him out
he is credible because of who he is and
then of course there were other
witnesses and that's what makes for a
good ufo case
there are other trained witnesses and we
have footage of that one
it's one of the famous three videos that
was released by the pentagon
showing the world public that ufos exist
they're flying with impunity in our
airspace and they've been here a long
time
so you know this is not to say impunity
you don't mean that they're exempt from
punishment they would try to punish them
if they could it's just that we can't do
anything about it
we can't do a thing about them if you
look if you look at the
1952 flyovers in washington dc a very
famous mass sighting that occurred on
multiple weekends and all the newspapers
came in sorry what what was that do you
mind repeating that it's 1952
flyover washington dc it's a mass ufo
sighting that was covered on multiple
weekends we scrambled jets
fighter fighter planes and they they
literally could not catch up with these
objects with these uh craft so
when i say flying with impunity what i
mean is
that there is a technology that somebody
has
an aerospace technology and that we are
incapable of defense or
offense when we try to compete with the
maneuverability
of these craft this is something that
has been occurring a long time
additionally there are incursions on
military bases
documented incursions on nuclear bases
where these vehicles these craft have
come
in and have shut down our nuclear
weapons
this happened at mail storm air force
base
there's a guy named robert salas who is
the man in the minutemen bunkers
and uh he he actually is a friend of
mine and we've gone through
the case it's now public and uh this is
something to know that not that these
things are hostile
just that they are much more
technologically advanced
than anything that we have we work on
reactionary propulsion systems
you know that all airplanes all
aerospace we still use the same rockets
to get up
out of earth's orbit that we did 50
years ago
so this is a different technology this
represents
not only a different technology but this
represents
possibly a different advanced culture
and it's not something you can get
around that the evidence
is so weighty for so long
that if people don't know about it they
haven't been paying attention
what do you think is the reason for the
visitation
oh i have no idea no idea i could
theorize all day long man
maybe they like our truffles well here's
one
here's one reason why i used to not
believe it now i'm not saying i do
believe it's just that i
remain open or unconvinced it's not a
matter of belief
it's true whether you want to believe it
or not i mean it's documented cases more
evidence for this
than there is for most things on planet
earth there's there's more incursions
there's more evidence of ufo presence
than almost anything there's
so many cases over so much time with so
many credible witnesses
now we have film footage radar footage
it's not a matter of belief
so why do you think that they look
somewhat like us that they're hominid
that they have two eyes that they have
to
you know there's something called
convergent evolution but it's not as if
all intelligence species must converge
to be like us so i'm curious why do you
think it is that they look
similar to us i don't mean to be coy but
i don't know that they do
and the reason is when you first start
looking into ufos you get all these
ideas
you're like they must be from other
planets
why are they visiting here that's like
you know ufos 101 the first thought you
got
then you're like oh they've been
represented to look kind of hominid you
know whatever bipedal
creatures the more you look into this
the more you realize all that is is uh
not
supported with the evidence it turns out
we don't know
if these craft are from other solar
systems
or if they're if it's stranger than that
if it's a dimensional
reality if these things are popping in
and out somehow
of of our demand into our dimension we
don't know we are so far behind in
understanding it
certainly hard physical craft makes you
think they're from other planets
for sure could be maybe they're looking
at us
like they would um livestock like a
commodity
maybe they have some investment in the
human species for some
reason and this is the why they show or
flex
on the powers of our nuclear weapons
which they've done a lot
uh additionally the other thing what do
you mean when you say that you mean that
when
we have done nuclear tests the ufo
sightings have increased
so there's a lot of information and
evidence
of the ufo phenomenon engaging
our nuclear process so everything from
coming into very famous cases like i
mentioned before
male storm in uh male storm air force
base
uh there is a ufo a disc that came in
and shot a beam of light down into the
nuclear silo and again don't believe me
this is
documented fact this came out through
foia this came out through information
acts
and it shut down our nuclear weapons it
was a display of
power so why are they doing that right
and they're not only doing it to us
there's also documented cases in russia
at the same time
at the height of the cold war so
obviously there's some sort of
uh message being sent where these
whoever is occupying these craft whoever
is piloting
these craft whether it be a physical
being
or an artificial intelligence whatever's
piloting these vehicles
they're they're showing us hey we can
shut down your nukes
at any time so i would suggest everybody
look into that so you don't just look at
this guy and say oh crazy guy told me
this
look into it this is something that is
verifiable fact
and if anyone if sorry if any of you who
are
listening are somewhat specialized in
the ufo field if you don't mind
putting some of the sources because i
can't get to them all that'd be great
and then i can link them in the
description
okay continue yeah and then i just want
to touch upon what you said
because we're going through this this
zeitgeist of like what ufos are so
people are like oh they're
from other planets i am unconvinced the
more i learn
i'm unconvinced this is a phenomenon of
just other
people from other star systems coming
here it the evidence does not suggest
that when you really look at the
totality of the evidence
it's not just flying saucers shaped as
saucers we have all shapes and sizes of
vehicles that shouldn't be existing in
our skies
again commander fravor chased a
tic-tac-shaped ufo
there's a very famous case called the
phoenix
lights and this is a mass sighting of a
triangular shaped craft
like a mile wide we don't have anything
like that in our arsenal
and people that you speak with who
actually saw it i interviewed a doctor
and a lawyer husband and wife
who who saw it and this this thing came
over it touched mountain to mountain
so it was over a mile wide and when it
came over them totally silent
it was like as if there was a bubble
around them of silence like all the
crickets stopped everything
and they're looking at what would have
been the bottom of this thing and it
looks like
waving of glass like they can see the
stars through it
and there's a lot of reasons you know
that you can see different
optics when you when you see these craft
because of how they're powered
how they distort how they navigate is
through a propulsion system based on
gravity as we know gravity
distorts time and space so you can get
an optical illusion just looking up at
these things
back to the beings because this is
always exciting people will say well
they look like us they're bipedal no
that's not true there there are so many
cases of the grays
right that's what you're referring to
this popularization
of the gray alien and yeah a lot of
people have seen that betty and barney
hill
were the first abduction case to
identify
this type of being in the pop culture
however
there's been a lot of reports of
different types of
operators of these craft they look very
different than that
so i can't say for sure that we're being
visited by another planet
i can't say for sure that these things
look a certain way
again these could be artificial cyborg
intelligences
that are just uh being controlled by a
super intelligent ai we don't know
who's controlling and piloting these
craft they could be drones
when you say that it's not necessarily
from
outside of our solar system then do you
mean that it's us
in the future or do you mean that it's
when you say another dimension
i'm unclear so please i'm uncle i don't
even know what another dimension means
i'm not that smart i i just know that
the evidence doesn't suggest that this
is just
people from zeta reticuli star system
coming in and visiting us because they
like our mushrooms i mean
i don't know but people have theorized
that these are extra temporal beings but
the nature of time travel
itself or by the nature of gravitational
travel itself you do have
distortions in time and space so some
people say they're extra temporal
they're they're being they're us
from the future i have no idea the
evidence doesn't suggest that to me
but the more exotic theories is this
idea of
extra dimensionals that there are these
kind of perforations in our reality in
our dimension
and that beings and yet craft can come
through now i
i don't know the physics of it i don't
know if that's true but i do know that
the study the government did on a place
called skinwalker ranch in utah
where a lot of these phenomena seem to
express themselves
they were doing so because they saw
deployment
they saw tears what appeared like tears
in the sky
and craft and beings come through now
whether you believe this or not
our government did study this ranch for
many years our
defense intelligence agency did they
thought it was a real threat
so my point is i don't know the more i
learn the less i know about ufos
are they just beings from another planet
or is it stranger
like interdimensionals extra temporals i
don't know
have you heard any great ideas as to why
they flex
in isolated situations for example why
don't they
now why don't they come to a place like
new york or toronto
and show themselves if they want to show
their prowess why is it always
in places where there's lack of footage
or secrecy
well we no longer have have lack of
footage you know there there's lack of
high resolution footage let's say okay
but that's another misnomer you know
because the uh
the flear pod the atler pod footage
that's it's not like an iphone those
things are targeting systems they're
weapon systems those are multi-million
dollar camera systems
they're just showing you a thermal uh
you know signature
because of they want to look for thermal
signatures to see what how these things
are propelling
so if you had a normal camera you'd get
less information
so the footage all be it square black
and white and grainy
gives us more information about that
vehicle the tic tac ufo in 2004
off of the west coast of california than
if you had a normal camera
but to your point your point is well
if they're here why haven't they landed
on the white house lawn
why haven't they said hey we're here and
a lot of people
you know over centuries have asked that
question is like you know what
what are these things and why aren't
they presenting themselves i would argue
that they are that they do so in a very
delicate
and intricate manner that they do so um
to a variety of individuals throughout
time
obviously if they wanted to show great
power if they wanted to show
a great force they could do so they
could shut down our nuclear weapons or
turn them on
so there you go maybe there's a program
in place i would like to believe it's an
educational program
that over time we're being acclimated to
this other reality
i don't know that to be true maybe as i
said before
there's a reason like a prime directive
if you're a fan of
you know star trek or that kind of thing
or non-interference
maybe they're just making sure we're not
blowing ourselves up
i don't know have you explored any
connections between psychedelics
and aliens personally yes
i love some mushrooms um because
you know they're different classes
there's like the mushrooms and there's
lsd then there's dmt which is like
psychedelic 2.0 and that one
apparently you can get to places where
you can speak to other beings and other
forms and i'm curious
if i've never i mean they're i'm
interested i'm interested in
you know the expansion of consciousness
and what exists within our conscience
that is untapped
so you know my psychiatric experiences
have been beautiful
i i never have communed with the aliens
or anything i don't know if there's a
direct connection
a lot of people have this these great
ideas that you know the planet was
seeded from
outer space on an asteroid by mushrooms
to enhance
you know homo sapien and bring them up
to in in intelligence and
i mean that's that's a joe rogan theory
uh you know i i don't know
i just know that people do draw that
connection
in the the expanse of our consciousness
seems a little bit less limited
when you open these doors of perception
through things like psychedelics
properly used
maybe ceremonially used and not
frivolously used you know going to a
rave or something
but i don't think they're the key and i
don't think they're the answer and i
think that if we were going to learn
something from them
about these visitors we probably would
have learned them thousands of years ago
human beings have been doing second dogs
for thousands of years
so i wouldn't go jump and do a whole
bunch of psychedelics to try to commune
with you and it's not going to work
why do you think it is that the
government released some of the videos
the tic tac video in particular
i know specifically why they released
reluctantly these videos because of
public pressure
pressure on the inside and pressure on
the outside there's a number of people
who worked
to get these videos released it's not
something that the
department of defense and the
intelligence agencies freely wanted
to release why give the public
information
about something that one we don't know
that much about
and two we certainly cannot control it's
a
needs to be perceived as a threat from a
military perspective
until we can identify the pilots the
purpose
and intent so it's not just like the
government's like oh
ufos are real here you go there's a lot
of people that
worked to get that information out
remember if you're a fighter pilot
and you chase one of these things and
you go start talking about it
people are going to think you're not
wrapped so tight and they're going to
take away your wings is what they used
to do stop you from flying
no fighter pilot wants that so now
they're trying to make it
there's actually new policies that have
been promised
to make it easier for people to report
these near misses they call them like
close encounters
and if we do that then people won't be
stigmatized as much
and we'll get more data so you think
it's because perhaps they want more data
and they just want to destigmatize it
you know i don't know that that's i
think they they have
way better technology than the civilian
world i don't think they need us anymore
you know for ufo data i think that they
can track it something size of a golf
ball coming in from from outer space
so i i don't think they need more data i
think it was just public
pressure people know this stuff is real
they see it
pilots see it individuals see it i mean
it's tracked on
on on radar systems it's hard to to
continuously cover it up
you know i want to defend you for a bit
because you take a lot of flack
and i feel like much of it is undeserved
we're going to get into some of the
criticisms of you
i'm curious as to what you think about
them but the way that i view it is there
are very few people with the breadth of
knowledge that you have when it comes to
this topic and this topic is extremely
pre-possessing it's frightening
it's also in rapturing and i see you
like
maybe george knapp can rival you so
george knapp is like you on benadryl
and you are like george knapp on ritalin
so i like george knapp at least from
what i've seen of him
uh i don't and i'm a fan of you so i
wanted to defend you
guess what what what have people said
let me know tell me well
if you look at the comments in some of
the joe rogan interviews
actually i don't know specifically but
what do you see as some of the the best
criticisms of you and
and what do you see is some of the worst
which one do you not pay attention to
i i've stopped paying attention to other
people's
perception of me a long time ago you
know
it's not important to my well-being it's
not important to my
spiritual evolution or personal
evolution uh
i i love i have friends have completely
different points of view
than i do but social media really allows
people to be
so anonymous that they speak like with
authority about something that they
don't have authority on so
you know yeah man people you know they
hate me for my beard they hate me for my
attitude they hate me for
talking if i say a word you know i
shouldn't be able to say that word
so i don't really care um
sure if i were to go in and read
thousands of comments
you know on the joe rogan podcast you
know that would be the worst thing i
could do
in my life because it's just like people
call you a [ __ ] over and over you
might start believing it
but uh ultimately i know who i am and
and the truth is i'm a curious
individual
i want to get closer to the truth i'm
not afraid of
of speaking up and and saying what i
believe to be true
or what i know or what i don't know uh
my my personality is not one to to say i
would get nothing done if i just
sat back and let things come to me i i
go for them i
try to dig in and find out the truth on
things and for some people that's
off-putting
so yeah i get love letters you know and
then some that are not so love letters
and i think the ones that are very vocal
are the ones that
you know try to diminish me or you know
say that i'm somehow a problem
uh all i'm doing is is making films i i
can't believe
people threat you know give death
threats for making films whoever
watches a film finds out the guy that
made the film
and threatens to kill him i mean that's
crazy
it's complimentary in some sense yeah i
i don't consider that a compliment i
consider that like uh
you know a mental disorder i you know i
i don't know people are very
passionate about the ufo topic and i
think it strikes a lot of
nerves and i think that you see that
polarization
in social media comments so what you're
bringing up
is a lot of people talk [ __ ] about me
that that's what you're bringing up
and fact that is true i think a
disproportionate amount of people
like to talk [ __ ] about my appearances
or what i talk about or when i make
films or stuff like that
uh i don't let that affect my my work
if something is good if if it's like a
constructive criticism i guess they say
i'll better myself from it that's right
and most of people who call themselves
skeptics are more
in the business of tearing down rather
than building up so it's not much
constructive
oh no yes skeptics are like debunkers
people that just
are trying to prove something without
looking at all the evidence i i'm hands
off there
you can't help someone like that you
can't help them it's a mental sickness
it's a
mental gymnastics well
to defend you and to defend the bunkers
there is a place for them because you
need to know your harshest critiques in
order to strengthen your own theory
but then at the same time i'm also a fan
of there's something called the meutic
method it's a socratic method of
eliciting ideas
and i don't see them as engaging in that
they may say that what we're doing is
trying to get to the truth but the truth
is also impart a
creative process and not just a purely
destructive one
yeah and there's a difference between uh
somebody who's skeptical
because believe it or not i'm extremely
skeptical i have to deal with so much
[ __ ]
so many lies in the ufo field that i've
i've
honed myself to have a [ __ ] meter i
mean i am
as skeptical as they come but i'm not a
debunker
you know debunkers are people that try
to just
say what commander fravor saw was a
reflection inside the hood
of his uh airplane and you know forget
the radar data
forget the other pilots that saw it
forget the internal investigations
through the defense intelligence agency
none of that matters he saw a reflection
inside his cockpit that's ridiculous
these are ridiculous people saying
ridiculous things
to try to presuppose uh you know their
their
initial assertion i'm curious about
about how you structure your day what
time do you wake up
and how long do you work for and do you
have to work in solid blocks
how do you get inspired
i don't advise anybody to take my advice
on how to structure your life
see um i i don't think i've got the the
model life
forget about advice i'm just curious as
to how you do it yeah okay
uh well i was a mixed martial athlete my
whole life so
starting at nine years old you know up
until 2004 is when i officially stopped
you know training i was a very
dedicated physical individual
so from training to meditation
to diet very strict you know i i trained
probably you know eight hours a day
so coming from that place
i had like a life-changing experience
with illness and then i i started on a
new path
a path of art and a path of film
and since that time my
daily habits have fluctuated
but the thing that remains kind of
consistent is i i don't sleep very much
i've always been one of those people
that just work
creatively best at night i go to bed
when the sun comes up or whenever i feel
like it
and i sleep as long as i want but i you
know i don't sleep a lot
you know average is like five to uh
seven hours a night
uh i eat once a day that's a another
thing that
has always been you know kind of for me
is uh i don't
i eat when i'm hungry i'm hungry once a
day uh
i don't know i like beer more than water
do you meditate
still uh not in the same way no my my
life
is uh changed a lot you know from that
physical discipline
i will say though that all those years
of intensive
training both physical and then mental
with meditation
i can kind of be doing anything and i
feel i'm in that meditative state
so if i have to clean my room or do the
dishes
you know that's when i take that silence
you know
what kind of meditation was it
mindfulness transcendental
was movement meditation uh it all
started initially with jiu jitsu and
then i developed a form of
yoga that was handed to me for martial
arts for martial athletics
so it was a form of yoga called warrior
yoga and it basically
trained me and then then my my students
and i opened up schools
all around the us and actually outside
of the u.s
to use a movement meditation that
incorporates breath and
very strenuous exercise that work with
the fine
twitch muscles and so i did that for
probably
20 years and uh you know then i did
seated medicine i traveled all around
the world
looking for people to learn from from
martial arts to meditation to
healers to seekers to you know i've been
all around the world this is before your
foray into filmmaking or this is
afterward yeah it's a joke i'm a
filmmaker like i
had no idea that i would ever become a
filmmaker i was a mixed martial athlete
that's it that's all
done and uh you know then i i got an
illness and it
transformed me i was not able to to be
physical
in the same way it's called valley fever
and um
you know a good year of my life i could
barely walk so i was it just
changed my trajectory and i fell into
filmmaking
and then i realized that um that i could
do it that i could do it well
how is it that you get the funding to do
the films
what does it cost i have to buy buy a
couple cameras
and i have to travel places to talk with
cool people i mean
it's all my own personal there's no big
budget i don't have a big company
it's me a couple of cameras and
and you know travel yeah i mean i i also
i survive off of real estate i manage
properties people i
don't know that because they've never
asked me but yeah this
you know i when i was much smarter in my
martial arts days i bought a couple
properties
so i manage those properties and that
funds my uh you know fuels my my film
funding
okay so pretty much you just need money
to live and then you like doing
filmmaking so you go out and filmmake
and then you can maybe
sell some copies of the film get some
money that way but either way you're
just sell funding because you're
interested in it
yeah it was never a question i didn't
even know i was going to put movies out
the the camera
it was like a it was like a gag you know
the camera was like my passport into
people's lives
right i just wanted to learn from them
and i found out real quickly you poured
a camera at them and they started
talking
you know they're telling you stuff
they've never told their families before
so making a film was just me sharing
my life experience what i have learned
who i have met and i was very lucky
in that aesthetically you know companies
like netflix were like
[ __ ] this is good and they were like
we're gonna put it out
so finally i'm making money on my movies
let's go through some of the creative
process what's going on on the board
behind you how do you structure your
scenes
um and is that helping you structure
your scenes
well yeah it's kind of like a free
association wall and that
you know i get my base ideas like even
the title of the film i go through a
bunch of different
versions and then yeah what i'll do is
i'll i'll structure
the footage that i have i think i do
this probably the worst way possible
in that i edit all my footage so usually
people film
for a few years and then they take
portions of it
to piece together a film right what i do
is i come home after filming
and i edit every single scene
in its full length to perfection so when
it comes time to putting together
a narrative in a movie i already have
these perfectly edited long-form scenes
and i'll go in and grab a piece from
there put it sew it in there
so i edit all my footage i don't ever
let something sit
how do you choose when to put some of
those interludes or some of those
recreations like for example there was
this
isn't a recreation but you filmed i
think it was john lear's
kid with fake blood as well as like
there's you walking into the desert with
a voice
i'm just curious do you see them as okay
i have seen a and cnb and you need to
connect them
what makes you create a scene that
wasn't filmed in field
right so so really for me it was when i
was
let me use a concrete example so the bob
lazar film so i've got a director's cut
version it's really long
right and i'm like okay what it needs to
be about an hour and a half
how can i tell this 30-year story in an
hour and a half with this huge movie
that i've already cut
so i really it's about paring it down to
be the most
pointed what are the most important
parts and i brought it down down down
then i got to a point where i was like i
need to put
something in there to show the moment
that i got notified
about the fbi raid on babazar's business
so i'm free to to film
i have my um you know my studio i can
film in
so exactly like it happened to me that
morning
you know i brought the texts onto my
phone and filmed at different angles in
that pink
intro to the film it was to give people
this cinematic
feeling of what it was like when i
actually picked up my phone and called
george knapp and bob i was like what the
[ __ ] just happened
so i insert these parts to the movies
based upon kind of what i feel
is lacking but it's really easy man pick
up a camera the world is out there
there's a lot to film
how long is this director's cut is it
ever coming out
i don't know i i i think i'll put it out
in sections
so the babazar area 51 and flying
saucers that's the name of the netflix
film
you know imagine there's thousands of
hours of footage
with bob that i have surrounding him his
life
his entire family all the other
investigations that i've done
surrounding bob's story
the movie is an hour and a half so what
i've been doing
is on my netflix on my um youtube
channel
i've been putting out extended bonus
scenes or deleted scenes i'm calling
them
and so that's so that people get to see
these longer interviews with bob
yeah okay now just to get into some
nitty-gritty i'm curious as a filmmaker
does that violate any of your contract
with netflix how is it that you can
reuse the same footage or you don't
oh no i'm a completely independent
filmmaker
my contract with netflix i let them
i let them use the movie for a certain
amount of time see i own
everything i own all my own content you
know i allowed them to use
the hour and 30 movie to put on their
platform but i am
the the owner of all my own content so
that that's how it works is i i gave
them the hour and thirty section
cool let's get to this background one
more time because i'm curious about it
why don't you take me through a specific
example how is it that you make the
connections
uh to make the connections to what you
said that what you have is almost like
somewhat of a madman
approach where you put different
pictures on the wall maybe you draw
lines and you put together i'm assuming
it's either a theory
or a theme or you're trying to prove a
certain point can you take me through
an example of your creative process yeah
sure um yeah well the main thing really
is
again it's i'm trying to uplift the
visual aesthetic
for ufo films right so i i want people
to
be enticed by the look and the feel
kind of the playfulness of a film i
don't want it to be this dry
ancient aliens kind of this happened on
this day you know
with my films i try to give a little bit
of personal character to it so that's
why i had like mickey rourke
you know the controversial mickey rourke
you know narrate with like a mouthful of
gravel in my film you know
i can barely understand him a lot of
people say that's the point [ __ ]
you know the point is to get people to
listen and and be enthralled by his
strange voice and he was talking
poetically he wasn't just
giving you factual things about the
movie i wrote him a script
that's like super poetic and weird and
psychedelic and um so
my you're talking about my chalkboard
wall so wherever i've lived
i've done a coat of magnetized paint
and then i've done chalkboard paint and
i get neodymium magnets so that they're
very strong super magnets
and i can put up pictures and kind of
use the wall
as kind of like how the movies playing
out
and and how to structure scenes to some
degree everything from music
and the soundscaping that i've done
which is very intricate
if you listen to any of you do your own
music well i i work with a couple
musicians
that give me the same uh
uh beats in sections of tones not like
usually full
songs and then i weave all of those
hundreds of sections into songs
there's a guy named red blue black
silver who i worked with for both hunt
for the skinwalker which is my film on
hulu
and then the babazar air 515 saucers and
he sometimes gives me
larger songs but he gives me a lot of
just audio clips so i soundscape
the films over the months by using
certain tones for certain people to
create to create an emotion
so yeah i guess the wall is kind of
where i can take these investigations
and say
i've talked to this person they said
this
this is the next person i have to call
they're going to connect me with them
it's like an active board for me when
i'm doing these investigations because a
lot of times they're happening
during the filming so same with the
babazar thing
when i got the guy who did babazar
security clearance
to work at area 51 at first he was going
to go on camera with me
and then he basically decided
not to go on camera with me because it
was explosive what he had to say he goes
i remember bob
i did his security clearance so all i
could do in the film is report on that
trust me or not i talked to the guy his
name is mike thigpen
and i got a hold of him after 30 years i
was able to find him
you mentioned george knapp george knapp
is an investigative reporter
out of las vegas nevada he's the guy
that broke the area 51 story in bob
lazar
you had mentioned him earlier in the
interview george knapp has been a mentor
to me
so george has has helped me with my
investigations
and we've i've done a couple films with
him he's featured in in two of my three
major films right you used some of his
footage in skinwalker correct
absolutely that was footage the world
had never seen he had been documenting
skinwalker ranch for like 20 years
and uh no one he wasn't allowed to put
the footage out but i was able to get it
for that film
yeah do you think aliens have
communicated with our government
explicitly yeah i'm curious about that
myself
i'm not sure i think it's i think look
it's step one time man
step one is the general public needs to
get
caught up they need to get caught up
with the fact that the ufo presence is
real that we are being visited
on a regular basis by an intelligence
that our flying hard craft that are
far outpace our technology and we think
we know how they work
our government thinks they know how it
works
they can't replicate it as far as you
know there's no documents that say that
the aliens have explicitly communicated
with
usa or russia there's nothing that i
would
concretely say you know a classified
document that i would say
that's probably real i i have obtained
documents that say as much but
the the the authenticity of these
documents will always be in question
because you can't translate the source
and the documents are they implying some
sort of collusion between the aliens and
the government or is it something else
okay so anybody that wades into the ufo
world
really really needs to protect
themselves from disinformation
there have been active programs of
disinformation
that have been admitted to by our
government
so as far as i know there's project blue
book is that what you're referring to
no no is that different well okay so
this is important project blue book
was the it ended in 1969
supposedly it was the united states
government
study of ufos now what people don't know
is that or a lot of people don't know is
that there were two ufo study programs
before
project sign and project grudge
sign as in sine wave or s-i-g-s-i-g-n
okay sign project sign and project
grudge
and then there's project blue book and
this is the one that's very famous that
everybody knows about where the u.s
where the u.s government said the famous
saying
where jay allen heineck who ran project
blue book
said that he you know one of the ufos
was swamp gas you ever hear that oh it's
probably swamp gas
it's a it's a very famous like thing
that people say to debunk ufos
j allen heineck who who ran project blue
book
later apologized for that because he he
knew the ufo
topic was real and he was mandated
to quote unquote demystify
the ufo topic to the public so project
blue book
was a sham and now everybody knows that
that there are cases that they can't
describe but their
mandate was to try to calm the american
public and this goes back again
i'm sorry i have to cut you off because
i'm trying to understand this so there's
project blue book
and what that was was a disinformation
campaign by the american government
ultimately ultimately ultimately it's
been revealed
that it was at best
a disinformation project in that
this was the official study of ufos by
the united states government
and people involved in that
uh process like j alan heineck later
revealed
that their mandate was to suppress the
information
was to minimize it was to come up with
prosaic explanations
and this is what that term swamp gas
comes from
now our government the united states
government also told us
that our study of ufos ended
in 1969 we now know that to be a lie
i told you about osap and i told you
about atip
those programs have now been
acknowledged
so our government did not stop studying
ufos of course they didn't they
represent a technology
that's far superior to what we have we
want that technology
whoever gains the technology that that
is
shown in these ufos
they win they win everything
it is a technology that cannot be
competed with
it can be weaponized if these things do
travel using gravity wave amplification
if that's true then this can be
weaponized
so in the history go ahead no i was
gonna
it's gonna make a joke
speaking of weaponized one of my first
questions to you was
has your curiosity been weaponized i
asked oh yeah
i asked the audience for a few questions
someone said that ask him if his
curiosity is weaponized i didn't get it
until i watched a few interviews and my
curiosity has been radicalized are you
kidding me
what i've learned through all of this
are you kidding me yeah of course man
um so that's so for your audience that
doesn't know i am
accused rightfully so of saying
weaponize your curiosity almost
every time i talk and i make a point of
doing it i think it's hilarious
i think i like to see people get so
upset about it what does weaponization
have
anything to do with it you know look
your curiosity is your greatest weapon
man
it's what allows you to ask questions
right if you don't ask questions you're
never going to even get close to the
answers so always make a joke weaponize
your curiosity
yes my [ __ ] curiosity has been
weaponized i got a few imdb credits here
for you
apparently you're still working on them
so there's extraordinary beliefs it says
it's a tv series you're filming
immaculate deception filming
indelible filming truth embargo filming
storm area 51 filming
and then post production on looking up
in moonwalker is that true
or are you just pretty much working on
yeah and and i think people are going to
be really
upset if they try to put me on a
timeline i'm one person
yeah i'm filming on all of those some of
them
i think are probably finished filming
and you know depending on where i
put my uh effort next you know i'll come
out with that film for example um
immaculate deception i filmed as i said
for seven or eight years with john lear
that's that movie uh i i could make that
movie
right now i could cut that movie it's
not the time for it
it's not the time for that movie um so
all of those are projects of mine that
are in the
in the phase where they can start being
edited but i don't know what i'm coming
out
with next i i haven't chosen how do you
decide when the time is right to release
a particular film
right uh so for hunt for the skinwalker
which was my second
big film came out on hulu i knew
it was time for that film to come out
because if you
watch the beginning of that film we
announce
that there's about to be a paradigm
shift about ufos in the public
that is before the new york times
article came out
identifying the ufo study programs
so because i had prior knowledge
that the u.s government was going to
announce through the new york times that
this was going to be announced
i knew that film had to be made because
what people didn't know
is that a lot of those programs
specifically tied back to skinwalker
ranch
skinwalker ranch had been a mystery
before my film nobody had
ever seen footage from inside of
skinwalker ranch
come out into the public domain for 25
years
never happened until my film
so i knew it was yeah no continue
continue please
i knew it was time to release that film
i knew it was time for that film
because i had pre-knowledge that these
um
ufo cases were going to come out through
the new york times speaking as a
filmmaker how long did it take you to
develop the relationship so that you can
get inside knowledge because if you're
just someone from the outside even if
you say well i'm making a documentary on
topic x
you'll get a surface level clearance
let's say and you don't have the
connections how long did it take you to
build it
what'd you do what tactics i have a
charming personality can't you tell
that's my best tactic no i'm not look
i'm i'm not in the military i don't have
a security clearance i've never
signed an nda for anything i mean
you know i i i'm lucky i i have a good
mentor in in george knapp he's certainly
opened
a lot of doors for me with with you know
uh witnesses i'd like to say
you know uh and and i think just over
time
i've been persistent about it i've been
interested in ufos before i started
making movies
so i i look i've been able to be led
into the annapolis naval academy
and and sit in on classes uh you know
have to do with aerospace
i've i've made great connections with
individuals who
who would have access to these ufo-based
programs within our within our
government
and i've never burned anybody i've never
spoken out of school
so the people that have come forward to
me i've never burned them
so imagine what i'm showing you in my
films and the information that i'm
bringing forward
there's a lot more that i've never said
because i
would never burn somebody for giving me
information
has the government ever contacted you or
followed you or have you received any
threats
or strange occurrences like lazar had
his doors opened and his
gun that was in his glove compartment
put on his seat and so on
yeah no i i've only been assisted uh by
individuals
within government and agencies i the
only strange thing that ever happened to
me
was that that raid on bob lazar right in
the middle of my filming and
they waited we have the documents that
show that they were watching
you know in preparation for that raid
while i was there in michigan
uh filming bob but they waited till the
cameras
were gone i mean last thing they want is
somebody filming the this raid uh
so that's the only images we have is was
bob and his employee just
snap some some photos during it and
that's where you see the 15 or so or
more people
uh so i've never had any negative thing
people
actually call me with tips all the time
whether they can go
public or not go public people now come
to me
and that's interesting so i think just
over time
people have realized and they've told me
this people call me after the lazar film
they're like i know bob's telling the
truth and here's my little one thing i
can tell you but i don't want
anybody to know it came from me and they
contact you over a phone text
email or in person or letter or what uh
it
usually it always begins with email or
usually begins with email
so they they they text my editor katrina
and then she'll sort through there's you
know hundreds of messages a day a lot of
them are from crazy people
and then you know she'll send me the
ones that are you know seem promising
and then some people want to talk on
signal or
an encrypted app or protonmail okay
let's get to this bob lazar raid because
i was
unclear about something when it was
shown in the film so let's say you were
talking to bob
some forested area if i recall i could
be wrong either way whatever you're
talking to bob i remember seeing trees
so there's some trees
is it away from his house or is it right
in his backyard
yeah well he he in michigan he had a
large property and the scene you're
you're talking about just for your
audience
so babazar has always claimed that these
craft
are gravity driven that there's a
gravity wave amplification
propulsion system in these saucers that
he
was able to to work on or explore the
power propulsion
in one of them he also claimed
that the craft was fueled
by a super heavy element called element
115
but a version of element 115
that is stable that where it's half life
is significantly long enough to
to to have these properties so bob has
always claimed that
in the film i was asking him
specifically about that
and about the claim that he got a piece
of these stabilized 115
out of los alamos actually people
thought
it's site 4 51 it's not he he claimed
he got a piece out of los alamos
national laboratory where they were
machining
the element 115 to send back to the test
site
i see but the people at los alamos
didn't know what they were machining
correct it's a contracted job according
to bob it was shipped under a code name
la-1000 and they would tell the
machinist
that it was an exotic armor and the
machine is not going to sit there with
spectroscopy and like figure out you
know the composition it's okay cool
i'm going to machine this precisely so
they would bring it in
and they'd machine it in a very specific
way that you can see kind of detailed on
my youtube
probably on my youtube site or a little
bit in the film and uh
bob did claim to to get at least one
piece out
from los alamos and he's been very cagey
about that
although he did do an experiment a cloud
chamber test
and there were witnesses and i've spoken
with all of them
there are witnesses in the room with him
at home and
i'll tell you this bob believed that he
had a piece of element 115.
his friends who were scientists many of
them scientists george knapp saw the
experiment as well
uh they believed that he had a very
unique
element that had properties that had yet
to be seen
and this was before laser pointers right
so they were doing a cloud chamber test
to show how light
uh bent because of the i guess gravity
differential
with the with the piece of 115. if you
had a laser pointer back then you could
just shine a laser
laser over it and if it was real it
would have been
but they didn't at that time it weren't
readily available this was 1989
so they did a cloud chamber experiment
bob's backyard i mean bob's a smart guy
he built uh two particle accelerators
uh one in new mexico and one in his
bedroom in las vegas
uh you know he's a very technical guy
and a really
interesting scientist and uh
so that talk in my movie
in the forest you know was
i don't know uh 600 meters away
from bob's front door right it's a
pretty significant distance on his
property
and we thought our conversation was
private and
in my film i i just show you a little
bit i show
the viewer that we are talking about
element 115.
we are talking about the idea that he
might have retrieved a
sample of element 115 and if you believe
that he did that might give a rational
explanation for the intense fbi
multi-agency raid of his facility
which happened the next day the day i
left
so uh that was the point in the movie
now of course i i fast forwarded through
that scene of the movie i am not showing
the contents of that conversation
okay so it's an insinuation that the fbi
or the cia or whatever it may be was
listening to you
even though you were 600 meters away
from the house oh they were yeah
so like with some sort of shotgun
microphone or
we don't place transmitters man i got to
tell you
it drove us crazy i mean bob initially
thought
i talked you know bob bob
i think all the fingers were pointed at
me from bob
and bob's friends you know i was the guy
with camera equipment recording devices
and when they came and said we know you
had a conversation
and we know you know some of the
specifics
of that conversation uh it terrified us
okay so
let me break this down for you so it
doesn't sound so cloak and dagger
we go out to where we thought was
remote on bob's property out of
precaution we're about okay we're about
to talk about element 115.
we're about to talk if bob lazar got
element 115 out of los alamos this
this super heavy element that apparently
was brought here 500 pounds was brought
here from somewhere else
and our government was was using it in
these non-terrestrial craft i mean it's
a
wild thing and if bob lozar's telling
the truth
just consider that for a second just for
a
second consider that babazar is telling
you exactly what happened the united
states government
is reverse engineering ufos alien
spacecraft they're trying to and that
they
they have some they have physical
evidence
of an advanced civilization not from
this earth
and these craft are you know show a
technology
that's way beyond what we have just
imagine that he's telling you the truth
and then he says he got a piece of
element 115
out of los alamos now
our government would want that back yeah
so the idea
is this is the one thing that's keeping
him alive
is that he's got this piece stashed
somewhere
so he's about to to tell me about this
and we're going to talk through this and
we're going to talk about how you could
get this out to the public
that's the premise here so no shortcuts
that's the premise so out of caution i
was like well bob
if you are telling the truth let's let's
just go out of your house and he's like
well no one's
no one cares this is 30 years ago you
know nobody nobody cares about me
anymore
and i'm like well let's just go anyway
so we go out you know to this forested
area
and then as i'm recording with him i'm
like you know
we have cell phones i'm like maybe i
should put those cell phones like
over there so i took the cell phones we
turned them off and i
ditched them about 200 meters away
and we kind of joked about it like who
cares no one's watching no one cares
right
and then come to find out the next day
he gets raided
by multiple agencies now you can believe
you know bob's version you know my
version
or you know the the the documents that
we have
found the they say they were there on an
unrelated issue all these agencies were
there
because of thallium that you know that
he might have thallium
you know that he was selling he didn't
uh not not in the way that
that they said so
in bob's experience this is not the
first time he's been raided by
multiple agencies and people that have
been on those raids i was able to talk
with one
and they're like this is the weirdest
raid in the world we didn't know what we
were looking for
but the way bob experienced it and you
have to take bob's word on it or or
don't
i don't care but this is what he said is
that
they came in they could care less about
this potential
thallium that they they quartered off in
grids his entire building which i know
to be true
i talked to the employees i have some
photos
and they were looking for
the element 115 this is what he said on
larry king and i stand by it as well
and the one thing they did was they
repeated
i'll just say the best way to say it is
they repeat it back to him
part of our conversation and it was
mystifying i mean bob immediately
thought i
i leaked the feds hmm they mentioned
your name or they just said you recently
talked to someone and this is what you
said
are we here i have to dance around this
part but
word for word the conversation
was relayed to bob there was no doubt
that there was recording of that
conversation
now it's not so weird when you find out
through official documents that they had
been
um surveilling both his home
and his place of business two days prior
to the raid
when i was there so now how did they
achieve that recording
i i have some friends that do these
types of raids
in federal agencies and i have spoken
with them
and i have learned that there are
multiple ways to do this
multiple ways for example for example
they have a very cool technology that
you can point at
any window in any house and the
vibrations of the
of the voice can be picked up off of
those windows now obviously we were in
the woods
right so how did they get it
um we have theorized over and over we've
looked into the technologies
we thought it could be our phones and
that that's the number one
culprit right now we thought our phones
had been turned into listening devices
because they knew a certain amount
if they had heard that whole
conversation
they would have no need to speak with
bob
okay so so clearly at some point
what do you mean by that if they'd heard
the whole conversation they wouldn't
need to speak with him
meaning that bob conveyed to me the
details
of the element 115 and potentially if he
had some
where he stashed it i see i see i see
so they wouldn't need to contact bob
okay because i was thinking that perhaps
what it is is you said that you go home
and you edit your footage
i know for me i upload my footage
simultaneously so it's syncing so i
don't lose a backup and i thought
perhaps when you went home you sunk it
up somewhere
and they have access to that and i was
so paranoid about it first of all
bob lazar had never let anybody into his
life to film with him
right yeah so i was every card i had
was connected directly to a computer
that never went online
there is no way interesting yeah there
is no way
that that anybody was able to get that
out of the ether
you know so first thing you know i
thought is we we went out to dinner that
night you know
did somebody come and like get my
computer card and like
but it was it was there right where i
left it and i don't see that as a
possibility
at this time i mean he didn't have
security cameras up on his home
but i don't see that as a possibility
and and just the mere fact
that they decided
to look at his place of business for the
elderly
they they didn't hear the rest of the
conversation i see
i've never talked about this but that is
that is uh how i
understand it you know someone that
doesn't want to believe bob this is just
another
reason to not believe in this this
sounds so crazy but
i'll tell you it happened and it
happened exactly the way i'm telling you
and i'm dead sure that our conversation
was monitored
that they were able to record that
conversation
and that they had full knowledge of that
conversation until i put the phones to
the side
and that's why i think it was the phones
because
and by the way if you write to them okay
yeah
so the second part of that recording
which is by the way now spread out on
multiple drives in multiple states
you know it's never going away that
footage like i have that footage there's
no stopping it from coming out
at it like it will come out one day uh
when the time is right but you know the
point is i think
it was the phones there are cool ways
it makes the most sense it makes more
sense it does but if you if you
if you appeal to the nsa who
who dictates some of these fisa warrants
and and you know these phone taps
they can never confirm nor deny so
you'll never get any information so i'm
unable to get any information
if that is true or not if it was the
point too bad too bad
oh wait why did you say that this is
what's keeping bob alive this is
something i've thought about i'm sure
many people
as well it's like okay if let's say bob
is telling the truth
why doesn't the government from day one
or day two
just kill him there's many ways that you
can kill someone like you know breaking
bad you can just give someone ricin and
make it look like they have the flu or
especially right now during covet
yeah so why is he still yeah that would
be a lie that would be a bad idea a
smart man like bob
you know has ways to to get information
out if he were to go missing so
um you know look again this is uh
this is a diff it's a very touchy
situation bob wouldn't even talk about
element 115
everything i'm saying now was was off
limits when i first started
filming with him because if you believe
bob
this is real world implications somebody
had to get
him the 115 out of los alamos a
machinist
that could be very problematic like
that's a real
problem that's a you get charged you get
thrown away for smuggling i mean that's
a bad thing
so if we believe bob and i'm okay if
people don't like i'm
totally cool if people don't believe him
i wouldn't believe him if i didn't have
the direct access to everybody in his
life you know
where i realized the story is true um
so i don't expect anybody to believe it
but if we just suspend disbelief for a
moment
and we believe bob i would
project that one of the reasons why
babazar was not killed for speaking out
is because one
who's going to believe it you know
before december of 2018 and the us
government
studying ufos who's gonna believe bob
not many people
so is he really a threat but a physical
piece of evidence
i would suspect that is the reason why
he's not just given ryzen
to be killed because they know he
probably has a backup plan so
if you are to believe bob i would think
that's a
that's an important thing i would be
careful if i was bob
and i see yeah when i was watching i
think it was called immaculate deception
with john lear
yeah i put out an episode of that yeah
when i was watching that there was this
clip with him saying
behind me maybe soon there's going to be
some ufos flying
that reminded me of what bob did is he
doing the same thing that bob did where
he gets some of his friends to film it
because he knows the
schedule of when these crafts are gonna
fly no no i think i think
john lear's got a few screws loose i
mean people are gonna hate me for saying
that you know uh
but he does i mean i i love john he's
like my crazy uncle
you know he he does not love me anymore
he's very mad at me you know
uh because oh it's a long story
it's you know john's a conspiracy
theorist he was very difficult to work
he sabotaged his own movie the movie i
was working on for seven years he just
killed it dead in the water because of
his actions
i mean he's john's pretty wild are you
allowed to talk about that
yeah i'm under no contract yeah okay
what do you mean how did he sabotage it
um well i had filmed with john for for
many years
and i had a really good relationship
with him and when it came down to
you know kind of his life rights and and
finally
relinquishing and letting me make the
film he decided to sign him over on a
napkin to his daughter basically
so when i had brought in other producers
and people to come help bring this to
life
you know it was kind of like you know
maybe there's money to be made
was his thought or something and
just sabotaged the whole thing so that's
my version of it at least
it's sad because he was a friend and i
really um
i care for john but he's i think he
wanted to be the
star of the movie and when i made the
bob lazar movie i think he was
very upset the movie wasn't about him
yeah oh
interesting yeah yeah but you know for
the record i love john lear
i wish him well i care about him very
much
just unfortunately he's sabotaged a lot
of things in his life and this is one of
them
as for why john lear hasn't been killed
why do you think that is
oh he's not credible
but in the beginning you said look this
is someone who worked for the cia
as a pilot and he has here's some world
records that he has
oh yeah no he he's done he's had phases
of credibility
for sure like uh you know look he's an
exceptional man at one point he was the
youngest person
ever to climb the matterhorn like the
guy was
an explorer he was right about area 51
uh the term area 51 he was right about
what they were doing there he actually
was able look he comes from the leer
family
so at the news agencies in vegas like
the guy has some credibility
you know he was right about
some of the back engineering of the mig
the russian mig
fighter they were doing and he got
photos
of the uh the stealth fighter and and
leaked them to a guy named
ned day in in las vegas a reporter
who was george knapp's mentor so
he had this credibility of being a guy
that goes out in 1977
takes the best photo ever of area 51
at lake level i have that photo i mean
this is like
um hold on just take me one second but i
think it's worthy
those are the neodymium magnets man
those things are strong
this is a photo from john lear this is
the
night in 1977 the year i was born he
went to air 51
at lake level the only security was a
chain
a hanging chain and he sits right at the
lake level
and he takes a panoramic of photos and
he sees in the distance
a car coming and it's kicking up dust
right so you can see it coming from a
long way away and he's like oh they're
coming
so he took that the camera he took the
film put it under his ashtray
put in a new uh roll of film took the
identical pictures
and when they rolled up on him they said
we know who you are
you got a camera give us the film pops
up in the camera
gives them the film they never asked if
he had another duplicate set
inside his ashtray it's a great idea
right so he comes out
1977 and gives us the best photos
ever of groom lake area 51
at close range and again nobody had ever
done
that before he wrote to me uh he said uh
jeremy
it's groom lakey [ __ ] let's go
wednesday
and we went that photo doesn't seem to
show anything incriminating other than
that there are buildings at area 50
no no just in 1977 it showed
it it shows groom lake like there has
not been a photo of grim lake
since john lear's 1977 photos that have
been that close up
so it's just at the time in particular
was really
crazy he's exposing this military base
that people
didn't even acknowledge the name of so
so john had credibility
and then when he came forward to george
knapp about ufos
no one wanted to touch it george's
bosses didn't want to touch it george's
boss famously said or
his mentor ned day famously said if any
of this were real
i would have known about it which was
like it's like the worst you know
attitude because it was real area 51 was
real what's going on there
and he didn't know about it so that's
when george knapp picked up all the ufo
stuff
and did his first report when you said
that ufos
are just some small part of a larger
yeah project what did you meant
phenomenal what do you mean i'd like to
say to the phenomenon i believe
from well the evidence shows me that
ufos is a very small aspect of a much
larger phenomenon okay so what i mean by
that is that
ufos appear to be part of a larger
phenomenon meaning
ufos are are kind of an auxiliary
uh implication of a much larger reality
so this idea that what we're seeing are
machines from other planets i i'm
unconvinced what we may be seeing
is an alternate reality you know maybe
it is something closer to
you know dimensional travel there seems
to be
another version of reality that is
occurring
and that somehow once in a while they
they
perfray and they pop through into our
reality
and this is not just from a cursory look
at the ufo phenomenon
this is from talking with thousands of
close encounter eyewitnesses who tell me
that this is something bigger than just
flying machines to give you an example
at skinwalker ranch
the report is that a piece of the sky
opened up like a
tear and out of this terror came
beings you know uh came craft
so so ufos is a symptom it's part of
this
alternate reality the phenomenon as i
call it
but it's it's not just about ufos ufos
represent
this phenomenon what other phenomenon
are there
bigfoot ghosts i i don't know if they're
related to i mean
yeah i i wish i i knew or i could stand
firm and saying
i know this to be true skinwalker ranch
is the best example of this
because you have ufo phenomena but you
also you also have cattle mutilation
which is often associated with lights in
the sky
so so cattle mutilation is something as
an example concrete example
cattle mutilation is this a ufo
phenomenon or is this a government
experiment
or is this a private corporation that's
going around mutilating these
cows and draining their blood in the
dead of night
nobody has ever been caught
during these cattle mutilations that are
homogeneous
they are the same across the board
they're drained of blood there's two
types of incisions they take the same
things
the genitals the sexual organs piece of
the cheek
and an eye in an ear it's the same thing
so the this is associated with the ufo
phenomenon
because the farmers and people that that
are cattle ranchers they see ufos often
times
during these mutilations so i can't
separate them
okay so we got ufos tied with cattle
mutilation okay that one i can
understand i mean
i've heard of that since i was a kid
okay what else
that's tied to ufos what else tied to
ufos i mean
i don't know the experiences are so wild
man i mean when people
you know get engaged with these uh
entities you know people have had
it's not just heart it's not like craft
come in there no one's flying them i'll
give you an example the aerial school
this is an amazing case in south africa
and
you know 80 kids or something saw these
craft
land in the field by their school all
these kids the bbc came the next day
and interviewed these kids with head of
harvard psychiatry
john mack john mack gets out there they
interview the kids
they all say the same thing these craft
came down
and they were little beings on the craft
with these huge
almond-shaped eyes and i personally know
two of the children they were at the
time children
and then now they're adults and they
they they
were within meters i mean within four
feet one of them was in four feet
of one of these beings bipedal being
wearing like a suit a gray alien kind of
thing
with these huge almond shaped eyes that
that she said mesmerized her
this is somebody who's not lying i mean
all these kids saw it again john mack at
harvard psychiatry went and
he was head of harvard psychiatry and he
went interviewed them with the bbc
it's a historic case and what was his
conclusion
that they're telling the truth that they
saw exactly what they said they saw you
can't make it up across
all these kids with the same
explanations and uh lisa and salma are
the two
uh females who were there as kids that i
know now current day
and it has affected their lives if you
look at footage of them
talking to john mack on the bbc and
they're talking about how they were
mesmerized and then they showed them
like images
in their in their mind's eye like a
movie
of the destruction of our planet and how
we have to be more
careful with our ecosystem and our earth
and we need to treat it right
or doomed well you know back when this
happened
that wasn't a huge topic of conversation
like it is today with climate change
so these children took on the burden
of telling people what these aliens told
them
so that's a good example of a phenomenon
that goes beyond just the hard craft
right and goes into the beings operating
them why did these
i know you're just going to have to
speculate but why do you think these
aliens came to these
african children instead of going to
some places that could make a difference
now
given let's say they're a court they're
the ceo of some corporation that's
exporting negative externalities in the
form of pollution
much higher than these 80 african
children why do you think that they went
to them
yeah i mean again you were right i have
to speculate i mean i have no insight no
it's okay who cares who cares let's
speculate it's fine i'm curious
yeah give me some ideas sure let me toy
with it
yeah yeah for sure so total speculation
i mean i'm not trying to be evasive
about it i just like you know really
when i don't know something dude i don't
[ __ ] know it
so here's the deal these beings these
craft these entities
maybe they're all playing the same game
and on the same team
maybe they're not maybe there's
competing agendas
and maybe this is a learning process
maybe
it's it's so weird to think that that we
might not have a
even a most simple grasp on what's going
on with ufos and
this alien presence whatever this is
maybe it's so much stranger again maybe
we're a commodity
maybe humanity itself uh in one of the
documents that
bob lazar read it called this containers
you know containers yeah yeah i heard
them yeah containers of what
you know blood are we containers of of
souls
i don't even know what a soul is what is
a soul so
maybe one of the crazier theories
you know maybe we're containers for the
maturation of souls like a nice wine
you know and we're a commodity in some
way just like we would
you know make sure that our livestock
doesn't spread a disease
that eliminates them you know we're
being
you know these entities are being sure
that we don't
blow up our earth with our nuclear
weapons because somehow we're important
to them
the nefarious version is where a
commodity
the non-nefarious version you know the
the positive version is that you know
we're a sample of life
and and they want us to get through our
primitive stage of
of warfare and self-destruction and
violence and hatred and racism and
horrible [ __ ] so that we can thrive in a
larger
community um i don't know
that was somewhat haunting when i heard
that
we're containers or that the aliens
refer to us as containers like
let's imagine it's true is this just a
somewhat terrifying thought i mean
depends on what you're containing
well again i mean we're talking we're on
real fringe territory here most people
they're worried about you know
where their next paycheck is coming from
my dog where the where the next
paychecks coming from
you know people are worried about you
know keeping the
peace within their own family people are
worried about not giving a loved one
covid i mean this this idea i think is
very important
that we are not alone in the universe
that we are being visited by
intelligence it's far technologically
superior to humanity
and that we've been visited for a long
time and that there is a message being
sent
in some ways to some people don't [ __ ]
up where you live
and if that's the case if that's what
really what's going on
it's it's an important message but in
some ways it's also
a fatalistic one because it doesn't
matter what we do they may save us if
it's in their best interest and they
have extremely
advanced technology so why should we
clean up the environment they they'll
probably save us at the last moment
no i'm i'm being serious if we're in
their interest
our survivalist well maybe their
interest is not just on the
the safety of the planet and the safety
of the the human species
you know regenerating again maybe
there's a different
investment that they have in the the
maturation of human consciousness
like some spiritual development i don't
know i'm not
particularly a spiritual person uh
necessarily i'm not a religious person
so i
i don't know i don't know are all of
your films related to ufo slash aliens
or do some of them touch on other
subjects like
near-death experience remote viewing
yeah i mean all those things interest me
you know that consciousness is not
contained
within the biology of the human body
is a big one to me because you know it
is evident
that these phenomena these beings
use a different form of communication
often telepathic or whatever
but my films that are released the big
ones you know patient 17 is about an
alleged alien implant removal surgery
doesn't get any weirder than that the
second one is about hunt for the
skinwalker which is a government study
of a
haunted property a property that has all
sorts of strange phenomenon
and the third one is about bob lazar and
air 51 ufos
and flight saucers um but i have done
other films on uh things like
nanotechnology
i've done one on something called a
space drive he called it
it's basically is a non-traditional
propulsion system these are short films
but uh those are of a lot of interest to
me
so yeah available to be viewed by people
on youtube or vimeo
yeah yeah youtube vimeo on my website
there's tons of information
on that and then i like doing a lot of
short movies my first movie had nothing
to do with ufos it was um
called las vegas and it's just a short
12 minute film maybe and it's just about
about
yeah people that uh were kind of living
on the las vegas strip
uh performers and whatnot they're kind
of jumped out at me it was very deeply
touching and personal and
kind of a spiritual experience and you
see these individuals
um just exposing
the their deepest selves it's pretty
powerful short film
speaking of patient 17 i have written
down here
what happened to patient 17 at the end
but i don't remember
why i wrote that down does that ring a
bell is that an incoherent question
no i mean at the end of the movie it's
it's frustrating uh there was a sample
of this material that was taken out of a
guy's body now if anybody knows me
and watches the film you know intently
and you watch it
i i don't this is not something i
believe i'm not pushing to my beliefs i
i
found somebody with an extraordinary
belief it's a doctor or surgeon
dr roger lear who said he's going to
remove an alien implant
the guy the patient 17 himself was not
convinced that this had anything to do
with
his other experiences of abduction which
he does
firmly believe he had so at the end
it's kind of like hard because what
happens to the sample
i don't have control of the sample i'm
not a scientist we got an anomalous
result
for from the sample meaning that the
isotopes within the zinc 64
came back from the laboratory as
non-terrestrial
that's how you tell location is is
isotopes
and this was odd so no i didn't follow
up this is not my life i'm not a
scientist
that's jacques valet the famous jock
valet he can follow up with it
he's a scientist so with patient 17
he went back to his normal life you know
he's just a subject of a film
you mentioned that there's someone named
richard dodie who was driven mad
do you mind expanding on that or
expatiating yeah that's a deep dive that
people will need to
really look into but no rich richard
dodie did not go mad
uh there's a guy in paul benowitz that
this was a situation where the united
states government
put disinformation into the ufo field
uh one of the guys involved he's a
friend paul
dennowitz uh benowitz with a ben nowitz
yeah this is a guy named rick dodie
who's a friend of mine
i like rick people vilify him and
they're so angry i'm friends with him
he's a good guy he was okay so who's
rick and who's paul
and what happened to them rick dodi was
was paid
to disinform the american public about
ufos
by infiltrating the ufo field and
spreading disinformation
and in one of his jobs doing this there
was an individual
named paul benowitz who was being fed
the disinformation and why it's so
controversial
is because paul benowitz went crazy
you know in some states because of the
you know rick doty playing with his mind
and his emotions
but in reality paul had had a breakdown
prior
paul was not fully hinged uh so that's a
that's a very famous case in ufo
lore about the united states military
manipulating the beliefs of people
within the ufo field which has happened
from time to time
rick worked for the government and paul
was just someone who is interested in
or maybe he's a ufologist some people
call them yeah he's a very brilliant
scientist
who worked near manzano weapons storage
area out in
new mexico and he was filming things on
a classified base from his home
and they were paul what's that paul was
filming
okay paul was and rick was tasked with
disinforming
the ufo public and and paul and a couple
other people
researchers it happens all the time
people that research ufos
you you get hit with with people trying
to convince you of something happens to
me
all the time i get evidence that's too
good to be true i get photographs
documents and i never publish it because
these people are [ __ ] with me
you think that they're government spies
or government
i i don't know of who they work for
but yeah certainly there i have um
gotten information that is feels too
good to be true
and when i dig deeper and deeper i'm not
going to fall for it
yeah i don't know who's orchestrating it
yeah and rick's role at the government
was what
was he a part of the cia or fbi or what
yeah that's uh i think it was osi
office's special investigation for the
army i i don't recall
specifically uh but he has done a lot of
counter-intelligence and
intelligence work for the army was this
disinformation part of project blue book
or was this just
a separate task yeah it was separate
project blue book officially ended in
1969
right and there was you know a certain
number of cases
they were unresolved and
yes but there have been active programs
about ufos since then
did the government ever pay civilians to
debunk
ufos as far as you're aware i've never
been
been paid by the government to do
anything about ufos so if somebody else
is getting a paycheck i'd like to know
about it yeah yeah i mean whatever yeah
um so i don't know i don't know i i
would imagine it's just like anything
within the intelligence community is
when you have
individuals who are predisposed to doing
the work that you want them to do
you can fund them to to continue that
work i've seen it happen
you know with with domestic terrorism i
have a personal
experience with that i uh no individuals
who were involved in that
uh and they were paid are you allowed to
talk about that or no i actually i i
should not but it's just uh there were
individuals
uh involved with infiltrating domestic
terrorist cells
and you know it's something that's done
all the time
yeah okay david fravor said that the
russians shot at a ufo on the ufo shot
back
i don't know if you've heard of this
yeah i'm unfamiliar
i'm unfamiliar with that okay i'm gonna
send you the exact clip and then if you
don't mind watching it because it might
ring about you know yeah that was an
engaged five-minute thing and there's
other
stories from other countries like
there's a story uh in the
back when the soviet union existed that
they actually
would chase these things and one of them
shot at some you know it shot it because
they said shoot at it and it shot it and
then it got shot down
and then they said don't ever shoot at
them again and don't chase them just you
can observe them but don't go after them
because obviously they have firepower
that we can't control because if you can
make something float around and jam
radars at will and do whatever you want
you know modern terrestrial weapons are
probably
not very useful yeah i'm not i'm not
familiar with that with that specific
case but i know that there was a shoot
down order in russia
uh regarding ufos for a long time and
then that that order was removed
to to not engage and there was probably
a good reason for that but i don't know
the specific case uh commander faber's
talking about
have you heard of other cases where ufos
have engaged with
in attack mode let's say to civilians or
to
the army no uh there there is a
you know there's an interesting uh
set of cases that the argentinian
government uh did
uh a massive study on that you should
look into
where these uh they call them chupas i
think how do you spell this
uh i think that was the name c-h-u-p-a-s
i'm not sure that that's right i could
be getting that wrong
but there was a i think it was argentina
and there was this whole government
study again man i could be getting this
totally wrong but i'll send you the
information later
sure but there there were some uh
instances of physical harm done by
by lights but i think typically with the
with the ufo phenomenon
these things are disinterested in us
usually they're doing
something like in the travis walton case
very famous case travis walton
was abducted uh and and you can look
into this case yourself but
he believes that when he encountered the
ufo in the forest
that it it let off a field that did
hurt him but then they they maybe they
swooped them up to to take care of him
and drop them back off days later
i don't think there's overt hostility
obviously there's weaponry that would
completely nullify anything that we have
within our arsenals of defense in any
developed nation on earth
so obviously these things are not
overtly hostile
you know that goes back to you know any
of these encounters
you're just not seeing attack mode by
these things
so brandon fugle said that there were
some of his employees or people studying
skinwalker that were actually hurt and
had to be hospitalized do you know of
any of those cases can you tell me about
the details
yeah so you're talking about skinwalker
ranch and the current owner is brandon
fugel
uh the the owner before was robert
bigelow uh
aerospace billionaire robert bigelow um
i do know that at skinwalker ranch that
there are a lot of
claims of people having physical
injuries
from the phenomenon itself i
remain unconvinced on that connection
and association between the phenomenon
and these injuries now i could be wrong
i do know
that psychologically people have been
injured
you know from engaging the phenomenon it
appears that when they do
that it it it appears to follow them and
that is something that george knapp has
talked a lot about
and uh if there's a grain of truth to it
you're going to find it at skinwalker
ranch
and when you say the phenomenon you mean
it more like in the wittgenstein sense
of a
family resemblance it's not just ufos
it's cognate topics like
what political rights ufos are witnessed
when there's a whole bunch of other
phenomena going on as well i mean so
people are having
visions they're having uh telepathic
experiences
obviously there's occupants so
skinwalker ranch really teaches us that
that ufos is just a part
of the phenomena it's a part of a bigger
reality
that we get to see from time to time
have you spent any nights at skinwalker
sure have yep okay what's happened to
you personally
to me to that i was aware of nothing i
just uh you know
snuggled with a friend out of terror and
fear i mean you know
there's there's nothing uh that i have
as far as that's a positive
oh absolutely he's he's a good big spoon
uh my buddy matt adams
no you know look i've had only positive
experiences at skinwalker ranch
i did just before you uh called me today
i did get a message from
robbie williams security head of
security
a guy named neil and robbie williams is
a
is a pop star uh from um
england and he came with me to
skinwalker ranch and me and george
happened his security guy neil was also
with us
and neil did claim
to witness a very strange
uh phenomenon which was this um like a
like a shadow being
i guess you'd say look like a a tall
being
follow me through the kitchen a
skinwalker ranch no
i didn't see it yeah yeah but i i didn't
see it
i never see anything like that i would
love to turn around and be like yo shout
out person tell me what's up you know
i never see this kind of stuff but he's
dead fast that he did see it
with another guy that was who's at the
table what he didn't know
is that in the defense intelligence
agency
study in this command center
that we were in did this shadow being
phenomenal had occurred twice before
he was not privy to that information so
if he was making something up
he could have made up anything and it
wouldn't have rung a bell
that's what's so weird about the ranch
you know so i didn't see anything
i'm i'm open to it being true i don't
necessarily believe it to be true
but we're talking about a witness who is
uh trustworthy and
he was seeing it live in person or was
filming yeah live in person the thing
apparently followed me right through the
kitchen
and he i could see this look on his eyes
and
and uh he told me about it and i have
this like a six minute audio clip we're
going in the car and he tells me about
it
and i recorded he didn't tell you right
then there's someone behind you or a
shadow person
no he said it's time to go interesting
and someone else saw it too you said
yeah yeah there was somebody else at the
table that was able to
see i miss everything man my back's
always turned i mean look in conclusion
we'll wrap this up with this man in
conclusion
you don't have to take my word for it
ufos
are real and enough evidence is out
there for you
to understand that if ufos are real
then that should make you so curious
about what they represent what alternate
reality
they represent there's an uncharted
territory a mystery here that ufos are a
beacon for
but by studying ufos and by really
looking at the history
of what's happened the credible
information there is an
alternate reality there's a reality that
is more expansive and bigger than what
we know
and that's what's so exciting to me
about the ufo topic
one day i hope to to learn more about it
and i hope to get closer to the truth
but right now i'm like you i'm just
hungry for answers
jeremy thank you so much do you happen
to have i know you got to go soon
or even right now do you happen to have
10 extra minutes because i have
quite a few audience questions we can
just hammer them out yeah sure
let's do it great thank you so much okay
rivulet
says i'm curious what he was like as a
kid if he knew he was going to be doing
something of this nature
if he was intrigued by the abnormal i
suppose
uh no i had no idea like you know how do
you ever know what you're going to do
when you grow up
you know i don't know that i've grown up
yet let's see what's next
okay then he also asks and has his
occupation ever gotten dangerous for
instance threats from shady figures
offered money to be quiet
i wish i was offered money to be quiet
but i'd never shut up
no nothing dangerous the only thing
danger said like the
the people that are so angry at me for
like
being on social media i don't know
what's the single best piece of evidence
you've come across in studying
the ufo phenomenon that's the same
question that i ask every single person
that i
first interview any time i turn on the
camera
and i've never gotten a satisfactory
answer so i certainly can't give you one
my best evidence that i have is my own
personal experience and the people that
have come forward to me
who don't want fame or to be known and
have told me a verifiable piece of
information that i can't show the public
for me that's the coolest piece of
evidence
viewer q says he wants to know this or
she
the three most influential perspective
shifting books
to you and why oh man
um well a story the plato's cave
amazing um
three most influential like the most the
absolute most
oh my gosh
i don't know man i read mostly like
martial arts philosophy books
so um art of war
another great book um
i don't know i like to read for fun okay
voyager 2
voyager uk 2002 said in his movie with
lazar he surprised bob with a photo of a
hand scanner
and apparently the same scanner was used
in close encounters of the third kind
what do what what does jeremy and bob
think about this well bob
no i'm glad people ask and that that's a
nice way to ask these people are so
accusational man people totally [ __ ]
misunderstood the point
so okay close encounters this clip has
now come out that the hand scanner was
in it now i've watched that movie
i've watched that movie tons of times
have you ever watched the movie
okay no i don't know what this person or
what you're talking about
that hand scanner was never publicly
shown
or talked about it was not even on
people's
radar till after bob lazar right
also in the movie they don't show what
the scanner does
how it accesses the bone lengths and
that kind of thing the the revelation of
my movie
was not that the hand scanner existed
and of course remember
things like close encounters people are
advising that movie
military people are advising that movie
i know people who advise that movie
so it's no surprise that they would use
a scanner that is used in the ufo
programs
in that movie but they never expressly
say it now bob lazar
we've all watched that movie none of us
thought about that
everybody said bob was crazy but he said
at site 4
they used this scanner it was really
weird it measured your bones i have the
audio and visual of him doing that to
george knapp
come to find out it was acknowledged
it was acknowledged that these scanners
were
used at area 51 and area 52.
this happened while i was filming the
movie
so when i got that image and i showed it
to bob that is a
genuine reaction he was like holy you
know whatever he said holy fish
you know this is the [ __ ] scanner i
never thought i would see this again he
didn't say all the f-bombs and all that
so people like to say because the
scanner
was in the movie close encounters that
bob just
made it up well guess what if he made it
up he's again
the luckiest person on planet earth
because turns out we now know they were
used at arrow 51 in area 52.
how did bob know so you come back into
the same problem if you want to [ __ ] on
bob and try to call him a liar
well he's the luckiest liar you ever met
then
okay we'll get to the next one stephen
paul he says artist filmmaker. ask him
about sensemaking
how does he navigate through the chaos
sense making yeah let's skip that and
then he wants to know ask if he's read
future shock by toffler i have not is it
good
i'm just i'm just asking stephen paul's
question okay all right
okay ephron did you have any problems
with authorities when trying to film
what happened and how did you overcome
them no no problems it was just the
you know the recording of the
conversation and the raid but that
didn't mess with me at all
yeah okay ephron again
do you think the government will ever
expose aliens to the public as
disclosure
no not not in like the big sense like
aliens are here we're going to tell you
everything about them it's too guarded a
secret because of the potential for
weaponization
efron also asks what's your advice to
other documentary filmmakers attempting
to create
films regarding et let's say i mean if i
can do it
literally anybody can do it like i just
grabbed the cameras
started filming got final cut pro and
edited it
very simple so just do it don't ask
permission actually that is the advice
don't ask permission and don't give a
[ __ ] what other people think make your
movie
joshua lysic asks have you heard of
wright patterson air force base and what
are your thoughts on what goes on there
i sure have heard of wright-patterson
air force base that is famously where
there is a place called hangar 18 where
they hold
some ufo materials so yeah i have heard
about it and what goes on there is that
they house
extraterrestrial um artifacts there
do you have any information that hasn't
been let's say disclosed or
not known to the ufo community about it
i i do
and and i will be presenting that
information when i can
back it up thoroughly but but i do
there's a warehousing program
that is very interesting it's been
quoted to me as a museum of paper
a location where there's a clearinghouse
for
all ufo based content over the decades
mike wixson asks how much of our current
technology is based on reverse
engineering
of technologies from other beings and if
you could provide some examples if you
know of any
yeah that that's debatable a lot of
people have argued that there's you know
a real famous
book that deals with colonel corso's
claims about
how uh industry has been seated with
certain things like uh
supercapacitors or whatever so or
what are they called whatever it is
superconductors superconductors so
i don't know if that's true i suspect
there is some
overlay with with uh but but i do know
this
i do know that the problem that we're
facing now with our military
is that a lot of these technologies are
wrapped up in black budgets with private
industry
who seem to supersede the power of chain
of command with our military
with with these programs which is a real
problem for our sense of
of government so there are individual
corporations
which have historically held on to these
programs
and they're not sharing information
some of this might be retreading some of
our interview but i'm gonna ask it again
maybe you can give a compendious
answer mike wixon also asks if we've
been visited by aliens since the
beginning of time or at least since
a long time ago which aliens are they
where are they from and how
and are there more than one species
visiting us
actually i would suspect that there's
more than one specie that's visiting
again if this is not some simulation
reality
you know if the whole thing is not a
simulation reality then yeah i'd suspect
there's different beings that are
visiting and uh the ufo phenomenon goes
back to the beginning of recorded human
history
saget asks why are they always so
clandestine in their abductions
and if they're directing our evolution
that means they
effectively are the creators of religion
so how does this play into the greater
picture
uh that's been claimed before you know
that that they've uh
influenced our religion and politics and
thoughts and
i don't know uh clandestine i mean if
you're gonna abduct somebody probably be
clandestine about it
i don't know david gibson asks what
fascinates him about aliens
man that we're not alone you know just
this concept
that human beings
are you know semi-intelligent beings
predisposed to war but that we might
have
other brothers and sisters and uh
individuals out there
life forms with other forms of uh
propulsion uh other forms of technology
maybe other understandings of the
universe dreams for the future
that's powerful that is what's most
interesting to me
okay and just a couple more voyager uk
2002
westfall ufo mass sighting in 1966
melbourne australia witnessed by over
200 school children
that's not even a question it's just a
point okay do you have any comments on
that look into the case it's a great
case
all right number two okay it's another
it's another point like that phoenix
lights okay number three
travis travis walton's abduction why
does nobody talk about this anymore
where are the loggers who are involved
in this
it has a profound impact on them they
don't like each other
but they never change their story
regardless that's true
not everybody gets along just like with
babazar
look not everybody gets along that we're
surrounding bob at the time but they all
agree on one thing
everything happened exactly like bob
lazar said so
you know same with with the other case
you just mentioned uh
you know yeah travis i brought him up
earlier i mean it's an important case
and
people are talking about it i mean i
don't know if you want to hear more
about it
someone should make a movie on another
movie voyager uk 2002
perhaps you should make a documentary on
it there we go there's a great one out
about travis
jeremy thank you so much i appreciate it
hey man i'm i'm just so excited that
you're interested in it you know
there's a phd level understanding of
ufos that needs to occur
before you can even begin to have the
right questions
but but the initial reason why people
are interested in this
is because the implications
that something is greater in our reality
and we have been lied to this has been
hid from us that our governments
have been implicit in hiding this
information
from us that is huge and so i i think
when someone gets interested in this
concept what i'd like to tell them is
you know
keep your mind open about it keep an
open mind
but don't let the marbles fall out your
head
you know there's a big problem it's
called ufo disease you start believing
one thing you believe anything
keep your head on straight look at this
uh rationally
look at the mountain of evidence be
skeptical
but don't become a a debunker we've
already decided one way or the other
[Music]
have you seen the skinwalker series i
don't remember who published a history
channel maybe
yeah tv series yeah what do you think of
it
i actually haven't watched the whole
series but i think it's great that
brandon fugle is allowing
people to document what's going on look
it's tv i've heard the criticisms that
you know it's exaggerated for the tv
show i you know i don't know
uh there's a mystery at skinwalker ranch
and that that mystery is alive and well
and it's worthy of scientific pursuit
the ufo
topic is worthy of scientific pursuit
people like neil degrasse tyson
shouldn't make comments about low
resolution photos when clearly he
doesn't know what an
atlear camera is a targeting pod people
like that
we should hold this information to a
higher standard it is one of the
greatest revelations
that we could possibly have if it turns
out it is true
not only are we not alone in the
universe which we all suspect because
it's mathematically probable
but additionally they are visiting here
that is the key point and if that's true
then that's going to speak volumes about
about
our technology and and why they're doing
it
i'm super interested in talking to
someone about the physics and getting
into some of the details and some of the
nitty-gritty do you happen to know well
maybe travis taylor someone i'm
i don't know if you've heard of travis
taylor yeah i've i've heard him he's in
that tv series
yeah yeah yeah that's right i'm trying
to think about uh
who would be a good person mine
obviously i would recommend that
everybody go
look at my youtube channel which is just
uh youtube
jeremy corbell and there's a
a long version on there called the
anatomy of a ufo
and that's where bob lazar describes the
propulsion system itself
how gravity wave amplification works
with the structure of the craft
that he was able to have hands-on with i
saw a video with him but it was from
maybe 30 years ago is this the one that
you're referring to or is it no i have a
new one
i filmed this with him it's a 17-minute
version
of him explaining and drawing the the
ufo
that he worked on but explaining how the
propulsion system
works with the structure of the craft
okay
okay all right well all right thank you
so much man
i appreciate it i'm a fan so any of the
haters if you wanna you can hate on me
as well then
uh yeah i i look i don't mind everybody
can have an opinion even wrong opinions
people can have
uh but the idea is that the the
individual it's not the messenger it's
it's the message if you're interested in
this at all
you know try to move the ball forward
rather than you know trying to suppress
people that are trying to talk about
this
uh you know the comments land flat
anyway i don't read comments
so you know enjoy and and hopefully
people get uh
curious and like to say weaponize your
curiosity
all right man have a great one okay have
a great night man thank you
do you have adhd uh you know i was
actually diagnosed with adhd
before it was you know kind of a very
common thing when i was a kid and they
put me on
must have been like a ritalin based drug
and i took it for like a week and i
um i felt horrible like i felt like my
soul was ripped out of me and i was like
tan
it was before it became so well known
you know
so yeah i guess i do i mean stimulants
make me
kind of tired like coffee and stuff so
you know i think i'm the same way
yeah yeah stimulants have a paradoxical
effect
on me unfortunately because i would love
i would love you know many people say
that they live by nootropics
and amphetamines and so on
but any time i've tried virtually
anything it hasn't helped
it maybe has made me worse almost
nothing
helps except it's like the reverse yeah
it's like the reverse stuff yeah
i don't know everybody's you know got to
figure out what works for them but uh